it's a big game for the dodgers even
with things wrapped up as far as the
division and the seating goes because
walker bueller makes only his third
outing over the last month coming back
from that blister tommy listello leads
off for the ace against bueller and he
got him swinging with a fastball the
stella the hardest player in baseball to
strike out this season the bueller just
fires 98 by him one gone for robbie
grossman wow that's encouraging develop
the feel for this pitch
this makes him feel elite
his chances for success if he has a
curveball are off the charts two up two
down on two k's marcus simeon pops the
first pitch up
right at home play will smith can't find
it can one of his friends help him out
he can max mutts he's got it and that
ends the ending and a one two three
first for beulah 35 year old mike fires
was a no-hitter on his resume against
the dodgers when he was at houston in
2015. that's leading things off
attacking the first pitch and beating
the shift with a cue shot to right lead
off man on just like that up comes corey
segal swung on a five ball of center
field gonna hang up for laureano angling
toward right center to make the play and
that's at number one here comes justin
turner sharply hit through the left side
base shift i don't know if there was
some confusion there or not simeon and
la stella kind of looking at each other
when it was first hit i was thinking
double play instead the dodgers have
runners at first and second i was
thinking the exact same thing this is
the third time in as many games max
muncie has come up after something went
wrong defensively for the a's and in
both cases in the first two games he
homer yeah that's swung on by muncie
driven to center lauriana going back
nearing the track midway on the track at
the wall and he's there and he makes the
catch bets tags at second and he goes to
third the throw comes back to the
infield and muncie almost got it out
well like you would you would think that
it would go out considering the ball
that turner hit should have been a
double play like last night really two
on two out and will smith coming up one
for his last 15. pulls a base hit to
left
wins this battle after fouling off
several pitches to bring home mookie
bets and give the dodgers the first
inning lead third inning in a
one-nothing game walker bueller just one
base runner as he's faced the minimum
over the first two high fastball gets
biscotti bueller's third punch out sean
murphy the cats are in nine hitter got
him swinging one two three third for
mueller on 11 pitches he gets two more
k's he's got four in the night corey
seeger to lead it off for the dodgers as
we head to the third seeger half the
time he swings at the first pitch heads
or tails let's see what happens on the
first pitch from fire he swings and a
fly ball to center field and deep and
gone
corey seeger a six-game hitting streak
his 15th home run of the year and the
dodgers take a two to nothing lead when
you're hot you're hot fielder
face the minimum once through struck out
four didn't walk anybody got him with a
high fast ball again 97 for his fifth k
five of the first 10 outs recorded by
builder have been strikeouts simeon his
second two gone fourth inning at 3-2 to
matt olsen he struck him out with a high
fast ball
six strikeouts for bueller through four
dylan floro is now on and release
as bueller goes four innings one hit six
strikeouts one walk grounds on right
side again muncie's there he'll race to
the bag and finish off a one two three
inning for floral 22 year old jesus
lazardo works out of the bullpen for the
first time since his first two outings
of the season perhaps given a glimpse
into what the a's pitching plans are for
the postseason some trouble brewing here
for lizardo in the eighth dodgers up two
nothing
and hernandez to hit with the bases
loaded and nobody out swats one to right
sinking in a hurry base hit pinch hit
rbi single for kiki hernandez to make it
three nothing four in a row of reach to
open this inning chris taylor stands in
takes ball four and he brings it around
to the bases loaded one
so they lead four nothing and what a
nightmare for jesus before he seeker
comes up seeger lifts a fly ball to
right center field moriano to the
warning track at the wall with just
enough room didn't miss a grand slam by
much the dodgers take a five to nothing
lead third first and third with two out
trying it'll stay on to face land
swinging a miss for strike three and
trying and after asking to stay in the
game for jake lamb strikes him out and
that'll bring up sean murphy to strike
out and fly to center go to against
murphy's swung on and drilled to center
field bellinger going back at the track
he'll turn and watch it fly a rocket to
center field by murphy breaks up the
shutout and here in the top of the
eighth it's five to one
jansen dodgers on for one of his final
tune-ups and a 5-1 game in the night
well the key thing to watch right here
is the command of the cutter and he gets
olson swinging
two gone in the ninth inning now a
one-two pitch
he struck him out and that does it as
the dodgers take this series from the
a's by winning the finale 5-1